I always knew that the Quest for Mad
martigan the search for Mad Martian was
going to be at the heart of the story we
were telling I went to visit Val in uh
in in Hollywood at his studio and he
could not have been more up for it in
game and ready to come be a part of it
we're looking for the sorcerer Willow
I saw that once long ago you defeated
the forces of evil you remind me of your
mother I'm gonna be really transparent I
was like I don't know if this would be
quite my thing but I'm gonna check it
out and then I binge all seven episodes
and I was like I would die for these
three women I loved it so much Ash let
me tell you I I just sent those three
women your Tweet
because I was like and because that was
for some reason for me personally that's
the kind of tweet that truly speaks to
me is like someone who comes at it with
a little skepticism and then Buys in I
was so thrilled and they were so
thrilled and they what you correctly
sort of saw there is that they love each
other and would die for each other and
hopefully that's on screen a little bit
you know a hundred percent
um I want to back it up to like on the
set of solo because Warwick was talking
to me about this and I thought it was so
interesting that it felt like the stars
really aligned like had Ron Howard not
taken over that movie would Willow have
happened not at all I mean it's a very
weird thing because that was you know
that was a hard shoot and it was
everyone sort of had to be extra sort of
you know have to have patience and and
and embrace what was it clearly a a long
and arduous process but in the middle of
of it what emerged for me was this close
friendship with with Ron and this
kinship specifically about Willow which
I loved and he'd spent a career having
people come up to him say like I love
that movie you know that's always been
one of my favorites and I grew up on it
and
he knew that I felt this way and that I
was one of those people and and I was a
good person to talk to about potentially
continuing the story you know and then I
think what really did it for all of us
is that we really had a point of view
about what that story could be and how
to how to make a Laura Dannon and and
and and the people around her Vivid and
and real like Willow you know one thing
I really love that you did is I think
people were like oh there's not gonna be
mad Mart again like what is that going
to be like but his presence is felt so
strongly throughout the the show what
was the conversation there and how how
that was well and that's another thing
where Good Fortune sort of Smiled On
This in in a very unusual way which is
that you know we I always knew that the
Quest for Mad Mart again the search for
man Martin was going to be at the heart
of the story we were telling and that
man martigan's daughter was going to be
sort of our protagonist and would have
to assume the mantle that her father had
sort of Left Behind kind and answered
the question that he left on her own
which I think is a theme in a lot of
stories that I like where you know we go
in search of our parents and find
ourselves a little bit you know but
where we could not have been luckier was
in finding Ruby Cruz who had been very
new to acting had just worked on mayor
of East Town wasn't even available when
we would started the casting process and
came to us late in the game and
instantly we knew that what she had was
not an imitation of thou but the same
kind of originality and sort of buoyancy
that he brought to the movie she could
bring in her own way to the series have
you spoken to Val is there the first
conversation I had and really starting
with with uh with work and I'm meeting
on the set and then Ron coming into my
life and us moving that forward the
moment this seemed to think seemed to be
something that could even be possible
I went to visit Val in uh in in
Hollywood at his studio and he could not
have been more up for it in game and
ready to come be a part of it and I told
him right then that you know the sort of
the quest of the Season would involve
the search for him and when we got to
shooting and we were sort of dug in in
Wales and it was really hard to get any
of our American cast out we simply
pushed that story back a little further
and left the mystery pregnant at the end
of our first season so that the
opportunity would always exist for Matt
mardigan to be waiting down the road for
kit and Eric we are talking about
conversations being born on the set like
this came from the solo set on this set
did you and Aaron talk about Continuing
empty's nest's Story because there's so
much to be told there you know there's
whenever you're with Aaron that you find
that she's constantly being approached
by people who love that character and
got you know what in a way of of all the
things in Solo Memphis Nest is kind of
the purest
continuation of George's Legacy because
it's so brief and so economically done
and yet
communicate so much emotion and pesos
and Humanity behind this Fierce girl is
this you know is this real heart and and
conviction and what was amazing about
Aaron was that she conveyed it in you
know one or two scenes and it's stuck
with people so strongly so everywhere I
go people tell me that that's an element
they love even within lucasfilm there
are people who passionately would love a
cloud Rider show so I you know you never
know it's it's a good time to be someone
who's a fan of stuff because there's
opportunity to tell those stories
absolutely
um and for Willow you were talking
already about season two do you have
like a finite plan a certain amount of
Seasons you want to do yeah I mean I I
certainly it's not the kind of thing
where I think
we would go as long as they wanted to
keep doing shows I think there's a enact
structure to this story and it has a
definitive ending for me that Beyond
which point I I can't see because my
sort of Love of what's happening in
television is that we're getting longer
form stories but they are really stories
with a beginning and a middle and an end
that can be satisfying and conclusive so
yeah I mean I would love to do a couple
more years but you know we wanted to
create a show that could be satisfying
at the end of this season satisfying at
the end of next season and and beyond
that you know whatever comes our way
we'd love to we'd love to finish it oh
so exciting well John I always love
talking to you thank you so much for
talking to you too
[Music]